hi everyone sal here from khan academy
welcome to our homeroom live stream very
excited about the conversation we're
going to have with linda darling hammond
before we jump into that i'll give my
standard announcements first a reminder
that khan academy is a not-for-profit
organization we can only exist and do
the work we do because of philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself so if
you believe in a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere which i
hope you do
please think about going to
khanacademy.org
donate i also want to give a special
shout out to several organizations that
stepped up especially as kovid was
hitting we were already running at a
deficit before kovit and as you can
imagine our server costs have gone up
dramatically we're trying to accelerate
a whole series of programs and and
various efforts uh and so our deficits
only grew and to help us close some of
that a special thanks uh bank of america
google.org at t fastly novartis and
actually the amgen foundation as well
and many other supporters foundations
corporations that have helped khan
academy get to the point that we could
be of service uh during this crisis now
with that i'm really excited to
introduce our guest linda darling
hammond who i would uh describe on many
dimensions stanford professor hopefully
she considers me a friend
a president of the california state
board of education and the founding
president of the learning policy
institute uh so linda thanks for joining
us
happy to be here
so maybe a first question i encourage
anyone who's watching if you have
questions for linda who's an expert
really in all things education and
beyond uh put your questions on the
message board and facebook and youtube
and i and we have team members who will
help surface it to linda and myself but
maybe a starting point is
given
the crisis that we're in around the
covid distance learning where do you
think we are in this journey how are you
thinking about it what do you think are
the most pressing issues right now
well there's several issues i mean one
is obviously because we are in distance
learning doing that as well as we can
possibly do it
and that means of course closing the
digital divide we're working hard on
that in california it means
being sure that teachers have the
training to use the tools and materials
well
synchronous and asynchronous instruction
in the right ways it also means social
and emotional wrap around supports kids
are going through a lot of trauma in
many many communities
and the experience that kids are having
is very disparate some kids are home
with parents who can work at home others
are having to be home while their
parents are at work
some have parents unemployed their
health you know crises in a number of
communities so whatever we're doing on
distance learning has to have a social
and emotional support component to it
figuring out what kids need making sure
that the school resources to support
those needs are also available
counseling and other
kinds of resources and then getting
solid distance learning mounted and it's
happening in some very creative ways
in some districts across the country and
certainly in california
and what would you say you know given
that i completely agree because there's
been so much conversation about
do schools open or do they go to
distance learning or not that it feels
like there's been a little bit of a gap
in
clear guidance on what good or even
adequate distance learning looks like do
you have examples of places that are
doing it well uh that could be emulated
by other places or just general
guidelines we've actually you know been
trying to do it on our own so it's good
for us to sync up on this
yeah well the california department of
education just released some guidance
this week on distance learning that does
sort of summarize what some of the
research shows
matters in distance learning uh and then
there are districts across the state
that are doing really exciting work
among the things that matter are
um having everyone sort of on a common
platform
training parents as well as students as
well as teachers and how to access
the materials and so on having
interactive uh instruction uh
synchronously it's not like just you
know the sage on the stage it's
being sure that
the things that are being communicated
um can be discussed among kids in
breakout rooms and you know in chats and
so on being sure that interactive
element is there having good materials
for asynchronous instruction um and
you're of course familiar with the khan
academy materials that a lot of
districts are using and there are others
across content areas that when those
themselves
are well scaffolded when we've done the
right kind of assessment to tell kids
where to tune in on the things that they
need to work on
and then bring it back you know in line
with the teacher and the peers for
further discussion you can get very
substantial gains in learning if you've
got all of those components in place and
that's what we're trying to make sure is
happening long beach is a place in
california that's doing really
interesting work around this
san diego many others i will say in long
beach one of the things i love
um and they they are actually it happens
using some con materials but uh they're
having teachers teach in ways and this
is similar to your approach to
reaching everyone the great teachers who
are really good on certain topic areas
are giving courses and
lessons anyone can tune into so
sometimes thousands of kids tune in to
teachers who are teaching particular
things other teachers can tune in and
learn the strategies that that teacher
is using and then you know they can use
the materials that are available for
practice and for you know the next
stages so there are ways that the
technology can really leverage great
teaching and materials that we couldn't
do when we were just in single
classrooms that we need to learn how to
take advantage of right now
that's super valuable
is a school district that we've been
working very closely with at khan
academy for many years and they have a
recently retiring superintendent chris
teinhauser but the whole team there
they've really been always one of the
most innovative school districts in here
and actually that project uh that's
actually a little skunk works that or at
least aspects of what you described is
that i've been working on with them uh
which is i did not know that i did not
know that
well maybe maybe there's multiple
projects but yeah we're doing that
exactly so that any some of their top
teachers in the district can set up
group sessions that any kid in the
district can attend so you're no longer
tied to your specific zip code or
neighborhood anymore
and they've had some where 2 000 kids
have shown up
because they you know
you know teachers can be famous just
like movie stars for the amazing work
that they do
and you know people can get that
experience i think it's you know this is
all about
inventing and sharing that's what this
moment in history is about
is to you know human beings invent
that's what we do you know we inquire
and we invent and then we've got to
share what we're what we're learning
and and just to double click on that a
second you know uh everything you said
makes all the sense in the world and
it's very much aligned with a lot of
what we've been talking about as well
but if i'm a teacher you know i'm used
to doing let's say five days a week an
hour a day maybe i spend some time you
know grading papers etc
at home and lesson planning
how does it you know i think the
guidance around making the the video
conferencing sessions more interactive
but does it become you know five
one-hour video conference sessions a
week what would you recommend that
teacher do do they do fewer shorter ones
do they should they do smaller groups
or it's really should they just
experiment and see what works
well you know it does depend on the age
level of the kids as well as what the
kids have had before so you know it's
it's a really challenging thing and i
just want to say this if you're teaching
little kids and you're trying to do it
online that's very challenging because
they're squirrely and so on but uh
that's where you need a lot more
interactive you know kind of materials
very short sessions
um you know interspersed with some
physical activity you know you're doing
some
pe in the middle of the
time that you're working you may have
low budget uh art
kinds of things that everybody can
engage in
if you're working with smaller kids for
example in the middle of the instruction
where you're also reading to them but
generally speaking
modest amounts of direct instruction
short amounts of that with lots of
opportunities for interactions
you know the
zoom breakout room is a wonderful thing
and when kids get old enough and have
been taught how to work in groups you
know you can pose some information you
can pose the problem you can pose the
question
send them off to work on it and talk
about it for a while have them come back
and share their solutions if it's in a
you know math or science context or
their ideas their decisions in a debate
context you can have them engaged in
debates and projects some of the
asynchronous time can also be done
collectively
because a lot of education is you know
doing things both individually and then
talking about it with others uh and
teaching kids how to manage their own
learning this is an opportunity for us
to help kids take agency and learning
and to really teach them how to set up
their own you know sort of learning
management systems how to use the
materials that they're going to use
asynchronously well
so that they're learning how to learn
because that's the critical skill for
21st century uh society is you know
being a self
managing learner
this is the time to get away from
transmission teaching which is i'm
talking and you're just writing it down
and spitting it back on a test towards
you know teaching kids to be
increasingly
engaged in self-managing in their
learning and we've seen that the schools
that are project-based schools where
kids are engaged in doing projects
individually and collectively
uh have had uh hardly missed a beat
in
the switch to online because the kids
were already learning how to plan and
manage parts of their learning they were
devoted to their projects because they
cared about them they were preparing
their presentations
they could present them part of the
homework sometimes is go present it to
your grandparents i love that kind of
homework because i'm a grandmother and
you know you want your
kids to have audiences for their work uh
and so they present in a variety of ways
but then the formal presentations at the
end of the year often you know to a
broader um audience in one case in
oakland the kids have been working on a
safety plan for their school because it
was a very dangerous school to get to
their last of end of the year
presentation was to the city council who
actually took up some new policies to
make it safer for kids to get to school
so when they do go live
they'll have a you know new path to get
there so i think that's part of it
keeping kids engaged in ways that they
really care about
and helping them learn
to be more and more able to manage their
own learning
and what's interesting about everything
you just mentioned is those sound like
best practices even if we're doing
in-person learning you know make the
students interact as much as possible
have them take agency have them apply
what they're doing maybe have an
audience to see the artifacts of their
work do you see i guess what do you see
are the what are your biggest fears
about the situation that we're in right
now and do you see some silver linings
maybe one of them is that some of these
practices become more mainstream
well of course there are fears i mean we
have a huge equity gap in this country i
mean it's you know we are we fund
schools inequitably we have a huge
income gap uh the communities that are
being affected by covid in the black and
brown communities that have
been hit employment-wise and health-wise
and in a variety of ways
those are huge huge problems that we
confront all the time and they are
exacerbated right now
so
the other piece of what's needed and we
saw this too the schools that were
community schools that had social
workers and wraparound health and mental
health services already engaged in
school were able to meet the needs of
the families
in a much better way we've got to do
that a lot of districts are
doing one-on-one um even distance
socially distanced home visits you know
where where that's needed as well as
one-on-one on the phone and on the zoom
and in other ways to connect with
families and be sure that kids are
getting what they need we're going to
need distance learning hubs and san
francisco is putting up distance
learning hubs for 6 000 kids where they
can come to a place where they can get
food and they can get
equipment and they can be online and
they can also have
counselors and social workers and others
to be available to be sure that their
whole child needs are being met so
that's the biggest fear is that we won't
step up and be sure that kids are you
know surrounded with all of the care
that they need but it is happening and
i'm just very inspired by the way that
educators and others are stepping up the
silver linings are
very interesting
because uh you know if you go back to
the beginning of march
we had this digital divide where about
30 percent of kids 20 to 30 percent
either didn't have connectivity or
devices that they could use at home
in california we've probably closed that
divide by about half we have five
billion dollars going out to schools
right now as part of the federal money
as well as a lot of corporations of
course stepped up a lot of districts uh
went into their reserves and bought
computers a lot of companies are
figuring out how to get
digital
access in much more reasonable ways we
should and could have closed the digital
divide
by the end of this year
well that wasn't going to happen unless
we had that necessity
we will have
teachers and students and other staff
technologically proficient in ways that
would not have happened unless we had to
do that and if you think about our
economy in california and i don't mean
to leave out the rest of the country
this is true elsewhere also you know the
technological underpinnings of the
economy
are
growing at an exponential rate so the
fact that we're going to have a
technologically proficient
um
populace
that cuts across lines of
uh class and income in ways that
wouldn't have previously
is you know a huge gain we need to take
advantage of it and people are learning
to teach in new ways
that we need to
capture understand share
and take advantage of
that makes makes a ton of sense and
we're getting a ton of questions here on
social media and you know one question
and this is a question that i have i'll
add a little bit too from facebook
zahedzia is asking i'm struggling it
sounds like zaya is a teacher i'm
struggling on how to perform quick
formative assessment in a virtual
classroom for those of y'all who aren't
used to the the language formative
assessment is assessment as kids are
learning so that a teacher can
understand how well they've learned the
material and where they might need extra
help and i'll extend that question you
know a lot of the school districts last
year had to just go to pass fail because
they're like you know we it's not
everyone has equal access
even now i'm hearing a lot of teachers
are struggling with science question or
how do i do assessments in a world where
i you know i can't proctor them
you know and this is all happening at
the same time that
things like standardized assessments are
are getting difficult to administer so
is there kind of an information gap
that's developing because of of this
crisis
you need information about how kids are
doing about how kids are doing and what
they've learned and how you've learned
yeah
uh there may be
i do think that we can help teachers
with tools for formative and diagnostic
assessment
one of the things we did in california
it's on the cde website is guidance
around using diagnostic informative
assessments and we've approved in the
state
about probably a dozen different uh
formative and diagnostic assessment
tools and programs that people can
access some districts are using them
regularly so that you can see where kids
are on a regular basis a lot of them are
very
short
assessments the smarter balanced uh
assessment system has all kinds of
formative and interim assessment tools
they're freely available to every
teacher public and private schools
that you can and you can burrow in on a
topic area to see where kids are kind of
you know in a domain as well as more
broadly uh and so we want teachers to
get to you know get familiar with how to
use these tools they don't require
proctoring they don't require you know
some special testing context they just
require the time and the tools right
there for kids and then you can guide
your instruction accordingly and they
usually scale across the entire k
through 8 or 12 scale of
progress
and then you can figure out what
materials you need to use the other
thing of course are formative
assessments that teachers would do
themselves
and it's a little harder perhaps you
know when you've got a video screen of
kids you know to check for understanding
but you can use the chat box you can use
exit tickets out the door at the end of
the class and say you know answer this
question tell me what you understood or
what you didn't understand and begin to
get those kinds of tools
directly in the mix
for the way in which the
the learning takes place
and then how would you handle uh
assessment in terms of even giving
students grades you know for maybe the k
through eight crowd that's not as
important the grades are a little bit
lower stakes but as obviously as you go
into high school
folks really start caring about grades
especially as it shows up on their
transcripts it's being used for things
like college admissions uh
how do should a teacher think about it
authenticating students should they just
go to a real honor code are there ways
to ensure that you know there isn't some
shady behavior going on you know other
people taking the test or getting help
things like that
well um
you know you i do think that we need to
be thinking in honor code terms in
general in the society and in life and
one of my kids went to college based on
the fact that they had an honor code
because they wanted to be really in a
place that
was ethically
you know organized around around that
idea the more we use authentic
assessments the more kids have to sort
of produce and defend and explain
what they've done and show it
the less you have to worry about
cheating it's kind of like the driver's
test in in the dmv
you know uh
you might be able to figure out how to
cheat on the multiple choice test but
you got to get in that car and you've
got to drive with the driver and you
know show that you can do
you know all the things on the driver's
test now in new york they have a higher
standard because you have to parallel
park as well as everything else um
but you know it is authentic and i think
the more we work with authentic
assessments of learning that kids
present and defend the more you can see
that they've really learned it
and i think that's the direction should
we should be going it's the direction
that the advanced placement assessments
the international baccalaureate and
others have been going in
for some years um i in terms of grades
my view is that we should
always be honoring the learning and the
the goal is to see what you can
get to not um
privilege people who've had more
experience with something who get there
faster so i believe in uh approach and
this is very well documented in the
research that if you give people the
opportunity to
um you know get instruction
try an authentic task
get feedback often using rubrics or
other tools try it again revise it
that what should count is where you end
up
in your learning as you've done this
opportunity to engage practice and
improve
rather than where you started and that
makes it possible for kids who started
further behind
to show the progress because they're
getting the opportunity to iterate if
you think about anything we do in life
that is an actual performance
you know it's
through that process of trying getting
feedback and trying again and the more
we grade like that the more we
uh actually drive learning upwards for
everyone and the more we close the
achievement gap
i i couldn't agree with you more uh you
know and you know this but a lot of
our resources that kind of camera
exactly that make sure that kids get as
much practice as much feedback that if
they they're in an 80 state that's not
the end of the world they can keep
working on it so that they can
eventually get to where they're going
and also 100 agree on the authentic you
know i've been brainstorming with some
educators and we might even make this
part of that schoolhouse.world project
where if a student is able to take an
assessment on khan academy say a course
challenge or unit test and they're
taking a screen capture while they're
talking out loud to show their reasoning
and then they submit that video that's
actually very hard to cheat that and in
a lot of ways you're going to get a lot
more texture than you would have had
even with a traditional assessment so i
think there's going to be some models
that that
you're going to get more learning
because actually when we explain what we
know we're actually solidifying it
in our brains in a way that you know
makes it more deeply understood so i
think that's you know that's the way we
should be going
100 one question for you this for me uh
i've always wondered and i don't know to
what degree you have jurisdiction over
things like the a to g standards that's
probably more the university of
california regions but i am curious you
know that right now it's you know in
california they have the a to g
standards every state has kind of the
you need this many years of foreign
language this many years of math this
many years of english
in almost every state in almost every
country it's still described very much
in time terms of time not in terms of
outcome and as you just described it's
much more valuable to think of things in
terms of outcome and some kids might
take a few months some kids might take a
few years to learn it but if they get to
that outcome that's what matters
is there a movement because i do think
these a to g type carnegie unit type
things are actually one of the main
blockers to moving to more of a whatever
you want to call it outcome based or
competency-based world
well there is a competency-based
movement there's been one for 30 or 40
years you know you probably are aware
that there are always people talking
about this and trying to do it we are uh
you know we've kind of been locked in
concrete around the system of education
that we've had for so long the
courses that are in high school that
most people think about you know algebra
geometry and trigonometry
uh were taken in that order alphabetical
biology chemistry physics in that order
alphabetical they're in the a through g
system those were all developed by the
committee of 10 in 1890 you know it is
time for a new approach i'm actually
just
now joining a international committee
that oecd is forming
because i've been talking with folks
there for a long time about we need to
have a new committee uh you know to
think about what it really means to have
a curriculum for the
21st century uh which we're well into
now but we haven't caught up kind of in
terms of our and this moment of
disruption in the education system is
causing people to think
what really matters
what should we really be doing here how
do we do it what's you know really
important in addition to you know
certain kinds of content knowledge for
sure
is the habits of mind the way in which
you can learn to learn you know more
knowledge was created between 1999 and
2003 than in the entire history of the
world preceding
knowledge is exponentially increasing
uh
technology knowledge is doubling
probably faster than every 11 months at
this point
so people need some understanding of the
concepts and structures and factual
basis but they also need a huge amount
of capacity to learn to learn
and that's what we should be
engendering because they're going to be
working with knowledge that hasn't been
discovered yet
using technologies that haven't been
invented yet to solve enormous problems
in the world that we have not managed to
solve and our way of counting progress
in education doesn't take these things
into account right now there are places
new hampshire is one of them
across the country that's really trying
to get to a competency-based system and
there are others that are working on it
but this is the moment to really be
asking and and trying to answer those
questions in new ways
yeah the supervisor
for one more question there's a question
from facebook
michelle morales capriati and i'll
extend her question a little bit she
says how do we
work to retain teachers at this time i
know you've done a lot of research in
this area uh there's a mass exodus of
educators right now due to covid related
issues and if you're if you're entering
the field how much of this is on your
radar at the state board and yeah what's
what's the solution here
well um you know we we
keep educators uh by valuing them and by
supporting them and so
number one uh where schools are open and
child care and other you know aspects of
the systems they need to be safe we
actually do know a lot about how to keep
them safe you know we know about the
importance of face coverings physical
distancing testing and tracking keeping
kids and teachers in small cohorts and
in the countries that have kept schools
open safely they've been very diligent
about those things
and where we are in environments that
infection rates are have been brought
down the curve has been bent
sufficiently we need to be sure that
teachers are supported in all of those
physical ways as well as in all of these
sort of
uh intellectual ways to do the work with
kids that in ways that can be
successful
same thing is true when we're in
distance learning is how to support that
work
so that it's doable so people have
opportunities to learn so that they're
being
supported and they're being respected of
course in teaching there are also always
issues of
adequate
training and pay
because we don't invest in this country
in the teaching profession in the way
that
many other countries do on a regular
basis so all of those things have to be
on the table
and again i think we're at a moment
where parents are appreciating
educators uh in ways they didn't before
perhaps because they can see
how challenging the work is with their
one or two or maybe three children in
their house however many they have
and can imagine what it might be to do
that with 30 or whatever the number is
in a classroom so
i hope we'll see you know a redoubling
of commitment to the
support of the teaching profession
yeah we couldn't agree more well
we're pretty close to time maybe in the
last minute if any final thoughts and i
am also curious you know how is the
state board viewing this are you all
viewing this as a one-year situation it
could be longer folks i know who know
about
epidemics
are saying we should at least plan for
for longer is that kind of part of the
conversation at the state level
well i think that there's a recognition
that we may be in and out of physical
school right now we're um
the california government the department
of public health etc getting ready to
issue guidance about how small groups
can come together safely even when whole
schools are not able to be you know
actualized or
in gear but we may have points in time
and we will in different counties where
it is safe
to go back to school but then you know
there'll be kids who need to be
quarantined or something they'll have to
be on distance learning so we have to
have this flexibility
in the ways in which a school is
experienced in the purpose of education
even if the place of education
changes and that's why it's so very
important to you know close the digital
divide help everyone be you know
actively
supported in that work because it's
going to be a reality
for quite a while and even when we get a
vaccine which
you know people hope for within this
year
um which will allow us you know i think
to get back to
school in person
we're going to have fires and floods and
hurricanes and other climate related
events that are going to make the
physical place of smuggling
a changeable place
and we will need to be prepared for the
that to be the
the way in which we understand that
people have to be prepared to learn
wherever they are um and that we have to
support that in a variety of
no it's a great a super important
message well well linda thank you so
much and i look forward to continuing
this conversation hopefully we get you
again on on this live stream and i
actually a lot of stuff i would love to
keep talking to you about of how we
could partner together to help teachers
and families around around not just
california but the country thank you so
much linda
pleasure to be here thanks
so thanks everyone again for joining
this live stream hopefully uh you found
this conversation as interesting as i
did i always comment about how fast the
time goes there's a many questions my
apologies uh that i wasn't able uh to
get to i will make an announcement we
have another uh leader in education next
tuesday john king former u.s secretary
of education is going to be joining us
and as you can imagine we're going to be
talking about a lot of the the same
issues about how do we do distance
learning right what are going to be the
implications are there going to be some
silver linings uh how do we navigate all
of this together so i look forward uh
for you all to
on tuesday
so with that
stay safe and i will see you in the
future live stream
you